Konrad adenauer-haus Anfang der Woche
wer die CDU-Zentrale betritt geht vorbei
an einem Stück Beton das mahnt Mauern
schlechte wie gute können fallen
die Parteispitze beteuert vor und hinter
der Tür unsere Brandmauer zu AFD hält
für uns ist vollkommen klar dass es
keine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD gibt
auf keiner politischen Ebene
afd-anträgen zustimmen kommt für uns
nicht in Frage die Beschlusslage ist
klar es gibt ein
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss
in dieser Partei gibt es nachweislich
Nazis
möchte ich gar nichts mit zu tun haben
Brandmauer Beteuerung aus Berlin schon
vor Monaten hatte der Parteichef in
Richtung AFD klar gemacht diese Partei
ist ausländerfeindlich diese Partei ist
antisemitisch wir haben mit diesen
Leuten nichts zu tun und hier wird es
keine Zusammenarbeit geben gilt das eine
Spurensuche die vor einigen Wochen im
Bundestag beginnt Friedrich Merz posiert
für Gruppenfotos was er in diesem Moment
nicht ahnt hinter seinem Rücken auf der
anderen Seite der Scheibe sitzt Mario
makowiak Mitglied einer
CDU-Gemeinderatsfraktion und hier als
Teil einer sächsischen Reisegruppe auf
Einladung von ausgerechnet
afd-chef Tino Propeller
Herr Merz hat gesagt mit diesen Leuten
haben wir nichts zu tun mit der AFD ist
es auch ihr Eindruck nein überhaupt
nicht überhaupt nicht wir reden völlig
offen wir arbeiten völlig offen zusammen
mir haben null Brandenburgern wir haben
in der Kommune Krauschwitz
beispielsweise aber ich kenne das auch
von anderen Kommunen Null Brandenburgern
cdu-gemeinderat makowiak und afd-chef
kennen sich aus der Nachbarschaft
diejenigen die kripala aus dem Bundestag
kennen
CDU-Abgeordnete sehen in dem Besuch eine
Provokation und fordern Konsequenzen von
der CDU vor Ort und mag das vielleicht
ein Nachbar sein das ändert ja nichts
daran dass der eben diese rechtsradikale
Partei trägt ich hoffe doch sehr dass
dort eine entsprechende Ansprache
stattfindet wenn das von
Uneinsichtigkeit geprägt ist dann ist
der Mann wahrscheinlich besser bei der
AFD aufgehoben als bei uns also das
heißt der Fraktion ausgeschlossen wird
genau
wir fahren nach Krauschwitz Nähe Görlitz
Heimat von propala zunächsten Sitzung
der Gemeinde rette fliegt macowiak wie
reagieren die cdu-kollegen auf den
Besuch
das ist in Ordnung warum hat er mich ja
nicht mehr eingeladen
statt Brandmauer gibt es hier das
gemeinsame Bier mit dem afd-kollegen
ist totaler Quatsch also wir sind ja das
ist total Realität also Berlin ist weit
weg wir sehen uns auch in der Freizeit
und deswegen geht's ja wirklich nur um
Themen Sachebene sollte gar keine
Koalition mit der AFD im Landtag möglich
sein in einem Jahr ist Wahl vielleicht
sind so groß zwei Parteien die über 50%
kommen aber die haben den
Regierungsauftrag auch wenn es die AFD
ist die Parteien mit den meisten Stimmen
auch im Kreis Meißen liebäugeln Teile
der Basis mit neuen Konstellation denken
bei Brandmauer eher an die Grünen und
berufen sich dabei auf den Parteichef
hat die Leute sich selbst hochgehängt in
dem immer gesagt hat keine
Zusammenarbeit mit den Grünen
Grünen sind kein Koalitionspartner für
die CDU sie fordern eine
Minderheitsregierung in Sachsen mit
wechselnden Mehrheiten vielleicht auch
mal mit der AFD Widerspruch vom
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten eins ist von
vornherein ausgeschlossen dass es
irgendetwas mit der AFD gibt solange ich
hier noch was zu sagen habe wer das
immer noch nicht verstanden hat der
schaut sich an wie oft dieser Neonazi
höcke hier Auftritt in Sachsen und ich
sage nochmal wenn wer solche Leute
einlädt und sie immer mit ihnen reden
will oder Kalbitz und hier Veranstaltung
Spaßveranstaltung gemacht der zeigt doch
was ein Geistes Kind ist hier im Kreis
Meißen liegt Radebeul es gibt einen
lügenmuseum mit wandschriften ein
bisschen stimmt es aber nicht immer zum
Beispiel
in der Heimatstadt von Karl May nimmt es
manche CDU ja im Gemeinderat mit der
klaren Abgrenzung zu AFD und pegida
nicht so genau
sie sind auch mal bei pegida mitgelaufen
ich laufe überall ich bin freier Mensch
weil da war auch Herr höcke von der AFD
ich kenne den nicht ich habe kein
Fernsehen ich kenne die Menschen nicht
die bröckelnde Brandmauer lässt die AFD
hier vor locken da helfen wir denn auch
nicht also
fallen ich freue mich da drauf das ist
überhaupt Gegner der CDU die CDU hat
hier einem afd-antrag zu einer Platz
Umbenennung zugestimmt politisch nicht
brisant der noch gegen die
grundsätzliche Ansage aus Berlin heikler
war es in Bautzen hier hat die CDU im
Winter einem afd-antrag zu Asyl und
Migration zugestimmt Einzelfälle
wir fahren nach Stralsund
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hier stimmten CDU
bürgerschaftsmitglieder mehrmals AFD
antreten zu was ihre SPD-Kollegen schon
vor Monaten veranlasste per Mail
CDU-Chef Merz zu waren
die CDU stimmt hier den afd-anträgen zu
auch gerade zu populistischen Themen wie
Gendern oder Asylpolitik und ja das hat
mich so geärgert geärgert und das
beängstigt mich auch dass ich dann zum
Schluss noch an Friedrich Merz
geschrieben habe Ende Juni und ich habe
keine Antwort von da erhalten für die
CDU-Abgeordneten hier die Zustimmung zu
afd-anträgen kein Grund zur Aufregung
man muss die Anträge an sich begucken
und erst dann überlegen ist das was
gutes für die Stadt oder ist es nichts
gut also unabhängig davon von welcher
ganz unabhängig wir haben den Antrag
dazugestimmt und das ist keine
Zusammenarbeit für Sie wenn man
zusammenarbeitet dann heißt es ja man
arbeitet zusammen und das hat nichts
damit zu tun dass man inhaltlich
vielleicht auch mal einem Antrag
zustimmt weiter nach Thüringen
Brandmauer hotspotland gerade erst hat
die CDU-Fraktion im Landtag mit den
Stimmen der höcke AFD einen Antrag zum
Haushalt verabschiede und parteiintern
heftigen Streit entfacht
es war ein Antrag der CDU-Fraktion so
und der hat eine Mehrheit bekommen aber
wir richten uns nicht danach wer
zustimmt sondern wir richten uns danach
was wir in der Sache für richtig halten
ich halte es für eine schwerwiegende
Fehlentscheidung ein Grundsatz ist aus
meiner Sicht eine Mehrheit mit
Extremisten verbietet sich Blaupause für
mehr Greiz Thüringen Besuch bei der CDU
Landrätin was hält sie vom formalen
Beschluss ihrer Bundespartei
grundsätzlich keine Zusammenarbeit mit
der AFD dieser Beschluss ist überflüssig
wieder Schmutz zu Ostern und Sie werden
keine klare Definition für so etwas
finden das Konrad adenauerhaus sollte
sich tunlichst zurückhalten wie die
ehemalige sed-parteileitung in Berlin
die Doktrin vorzugeben was man denken
und zu fühlen und zu tun und zu lassen
hat
die beschworene Brandmauer wirkt eher
wie der durchlässige Bauzaun neben der
Parteizentrale zurück in Berlin am Ende
und gleichzeitig am Anfang der Reise
dieser
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss gilt über
Album das ist keine Zusammenarbeit gibt
was bedeutet das für diese
CDU-Politiker vor Ort wenn sie sagen das
geht eigentlich nicht aber genau das
machen sie ja nein das gilt für Sie auch
hilflos wirkende Appelle an eine Partei
die sich nicht mal einig ist was keine
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD oder
Brandmauer eigentlich meint
[Musik]